welcome to this video playing
international master air Camarena how's
the name of the sky rufino Camarena
jimenez no I don't know this guy I have
played him though one and a half points
out of two so what is he doing the
gruenfelder will we get this strange age
forced up again no the Kings in yen I
got this request for the four pawns I
had tried it once and actually won the
game despite pretty much not knowing
anything mmm yeah I got a slight cold
yesterday we were sitting outside a very
nice weather but in the evening it did
copter got somewhat caught and wasn't a
good idea to stay out out of the pin out
of the house weather was just a t-shirt
on yeah 92 where I know II five is the
the normal move but this I really don't
know he had at least fields I can get in
some moves without aha can get in some
moves without her knowing so much wow
really amazing hmm
yeah it looks strange but maybe maybe
you can play chess like that maybe you
can I'm not sure about this one but yeah
it's not clear way wants to go maybe
root gave aid okay ship yeah this is the
problem the bishop now is somewhat
exposed can I go can I go here just play
it playing in super straightforward
fashion 98 i will take out but he can
play night you follow this is sam
certainly possible there should be four
and a six ms not not going for that ok i
just go in for I mean he can I need I
need to make sure these pieces are safe
so and the rook on g7 has really a
strange piece yeah I probably didn't
didn't play that particularly well but
at least there was quick doing it and he
is he's certainly certainly very much
irritated if you can almost feel that
he's sitting there and ask himself what
the heck is going on um how to play it
died of t2 t3 maybe as I saw that d5
hangs but this is a bit of a gamble just
speculating that this is probably not so
great i played bishops III maybe you
should do it still yeah probably you
should take it
I want to get rid of the bishop on order
strong knight on d5 on d5 I have 95 and
my ideas bishop at 325 you are getting
this piece on a 3 into play again or
maybe Queen d5 the right moment Queen d5
can also be nice and there's also the
idea a tick if I check 25 and I can take
with the Roku still I can play it 96
with the queen bee three check it coming
and Queen takes Queen d5 check rookie
one assessors totally weakening the back
rank I can even try it here yeah I give
this check check give this check first
and then take d6 there is sunlight f7
really a looming
yeah Andrew key one rupee agents also
very strong okay so he's giving up
giving up the exchange but I i can play
rookie one as well I wonder if this is
even better yeah I think this is a
strong rook e8 is the big threat and
Bishop takes you one there is Queenie
five check maybe this is stronger even
Queenie five check but is it's got
pepper okay Bishop you one okay one is
very strong I mean rook e8 is very
substantial and he cannot play Bishop d7
because of Queen e5 checking g8 Bishop
f7 check at this world will be a check
made now that's very difficult to defend
I mean if there is a defense I don't see
one at the moment his King is really
under huge pressure
maybe you can play okay OOP d7 I know a
froakie 8 and I can take with the bishop
now okay first check Queenie five if
this is an immediate win Luke g7 night
f7 is a win but you can go to g8 and
then I don't see a continuation now but
this is strong i think okeee does just
very strong and there are other other
things kingi 798 check and all pieces to
attack um no cannot believe that this
should be should be a win let's let's
check it here I can give the check here
first King g8 Queen here or rook e8 here
doctor I don't see a win at the moment
maybe I'm just just blind here the check
in g8 push about some the shop f 79 f 7
don't I don't see a win now probably
just totally blind I'll give the check
kingi 7 25 25 of them still I don't see
you made it is thatis a very strong
attack though I mean that calf I have i
also have g3 at one moment probably king
age 6 from g3 can take he can really
just take it on age 5 or night f7 he can
also take age 5 it's all very hard to
believe but maybe maybe this check
teenage 5g three-time morning yeah I
don't have any time left we just took it
this earth didn't expect maybe he's I'm
just calculating it all wrong don't see
a mate I don't see it I mean I don't
know also the hell is he let's see a
move for him but um yeah this yeah this
is this is okay now probably it that was
it must be winning but i didn't i didn't
really see a totally convincing way
let's go back to the situation night f 7
a-9 f7 is just winning the Queen now and
shut such idiot right f7 is just winning
the queer play rook e1 sometimes
sometimes you really wonder yeah white
is totally winning here night f7 is just
really in the Queen I chats not exactly
difficult okay I wanted to to make it I
don't know
more difficult neither said stoning the
Queen as though they did this it did
this and the position from um jack yeah
remarkable yeah okay and now one it is
it is still winning rookie eight is made
check Queen GA doesn't mater and let's
let's now check how it is a made my life
seven check okay just as this is
believable I'm ending in a mid takes and
Bishop Jake's yeah of course it looks
very nice but yeah it is this is Jack
but this is also winning what the ideas
here rook c8 Dolce I only saw that one
and here i had actually expected him to
take and then I thought just g3 should
be it should be good but he's got this
one yeah there is no made ready it's got
quindi one check I was thinking about
this kind of moves queen of six but
Jerry's this check I'm not working look
see six of the defense yeah and I met I
made life much much too difficult oops
sorry it was a bit too much yeah yeah
Jim yeah rook rook c8 was also strong
intending night f5 yeah that sets out
what so totally winning check yeah what
if we had game i hope you enjoyed it
there was some some really strange
decisions not have seven wasn't exactly
difficult but somehow i didn't do it
thanks for watching